foreign
[Music]
Robertson and I'm going to talk about
polymyrobial biofilms and the importance
of building better biofilm models for
research translation so I'm a research
fellow from the national biofilms
Innovation Center at the University of
Nottingham in the United Kingdom
my work has focused in the last few few
years on building this area and just
building models that will help translate
research from the University environment
into academic
uh sorry I'll start that again
right okay so hello my name's Sean
Robertson and I'm a research fellow at
the University of Nottingham in the
United Kingdom
I'm going to be talking about
polymicrobial biofilms and the
importance of building better biofilm
models for research translation
so when we think about microbial
biofilms and why they are important it's
not just that they are involved in
healthcare there is a wider impact in
the industrial area as well often with
these microbial biofilms they are a
microbial in nature and in this
terminology that means more than three
species of microbes are involved in
forming that biofoam and these have a
large range of effects in healthcare
with morbidity and mortality and an
industry with a large economical burden
as well and this has been Quantified
recently in a report in mpga biofilms
and microbiomes with the economic
significance of biofilms bisector being
evaluated and this is grossed over
nearly four trillion dollars is globally
and with a large component of this being
due to microbially influenced corrosion
when we exclude the microbial inference
corrosion as you can see on the right
hand side of this pie chart there's a
significant medical and human health
issue but also Personal Care oral health
home care and so on and so forth
and focusing in on the economic
significance of these in the healthcare
setting we can see that there's a large
impact across a number of areas that
some of you may be familiar with and
especially those being highlighted being
things like wind healing which is one of
the largest economic impacts globally
and also other diseases such as the
orphan disease cystic fibrosis which is
typified by microbial infections
especially later in adulthood and
predominantly through a bacteria known
as pseudomonas originosa and when we
represent this as a kind of overview of
the sites of infections in humans you
can have the oral cavity which is a very
well
um described and literature Rich area of
the investigation of biofilms and
polymicrobial biofilm models and then
into other areas such as
um cutaneous sites vascular catheters
intra-abdominal sites UTIs with
catheters and also lower reproductive
attack burn wounds wounds and the
respiratory area as well
so when we talk about a biofilm the
conceptual model which has been really
well interested in this recent review
is where we have a surface
microbe comes along
colonizes that surface and what is known
as a reversible attachment and this is
seen on the very far left of this um
schematic then we have the transition to
irreversible attachment production of
extracellular polymeric substances with
cell clustering and which essentially
glues it to that surface and this is the
beginning of what we call a biofoam and
maturation
and then into the microcode information
and then dispersal through various
methods whether that's active or passive
yet when we look to capture model which
we can replicate in lab in vitro this is
not the case and this has been typified
when we look at flow in open source
where we set us in as heterogeneous
um massive biofilms that form with
structures that are mushroom-like in
cases and also have these pellicles
forming Out of Water streams and this is
in a open flow system rather than the
traditional flow systems we see in labs
and then we look at cystic fibrosis
which I mentioned earlier we see these
self-aggregated biofilms where they're
not actually attached to a surface which
has normally been a typical definition
of what biofilm is
and then looking at another area winds
where we see these biofilms that are
polymicrobial in nature
um and typified by some attachment to
areas but then also present in the wound
accident as well
so this leads the questions of
how do we better translate research and
how do we better mimic these well what
we need to do is we need to consider a
number of factors
and this is very well summarized and
reviewed by Pearl egg where we need to
look at how these microbials species mix
are they mixed are they segregated do
they layer and do they change over time
and with those chemicals as byproducts
metabolites are these mixed segregated
diffusable dispersible and are they
metabolized by other microbial species
these all need to be considered when
looking in context of poly microbial
biofilms
and then this can also have other
effects where you can have physical
interactions such as this typified here
you can have a fungi yeast body with a
hyphenating cell such as candidate Hall
Wilkins and then you can have attachment
of microbes that can be either positive
or negative for the fungal interaction
but then also these interactions can
modulate the host response as well so
this is a complex environment with
complex interactions yet traditionally
we have tested on single species and
just to give an idea of what can happen
in the system fibrotic lung with
patients that are colonized by a number
of microbial species such as bokodilia
stanamorphis pseudomosa regionosa and
candidal begins they produce a number of
molecules that are used in cell cell
communication
and these are known as Quorum sensing
molecules so what we can see is there's
a number of impacts where we have
vertical data having negative inhibitory
impacts of the Corn sensing biofoam
formation and variance pseudomonas
originosa but then we can also have
things like pseudomos original so
producing its corn sensor molecules they
can negatively impact the filamentation
so the formation of hyphae by the yeast
body of candida albicans and cons and
conversely Canada options can produce a
compound known as pharmazole that can
then impact on the Quorum sensing of
pseudomonosaurus so it's quite evident
that there are complex interactions that
are known in the literature that need to
be taken into account when we model
these microbial species and just to give
some further real life examples we have
this where the dental biofilms are very
well established area where we know the
interactions and there can also be a
hierarchical and structuring of the
early bridging organisms which attack
attach to the Dentin surface of the
tooth followed by attachment of
secondary and tertiary colonizing
microbial species
and generally what happens is it's the
tertiary microbial species such as
performers gingivals and fusobacteria
nucleatum they cause things like bad
breath and other oral related disease
such as gingivitis
and then when we look at faction
especially in a systemic infection we
have staphylococcus aureus cooperating
with um candida albicans so this is the
sc5d14 what we can see here is the
invasion of uh Mouse tongue tissue by
the Canada albicans hyphae and the
staphylococcusaurus attached to these
and travel with the hyphae yet when we
knock out a protein expressed on the
surface of Canada albicans called als3
we see that staphylococcus does not then
attach and does then not invade
alongside the candidate or begins
Invasion and then when that is
recomplemented Into The Knockout we see
that that function is restored so it's
quite evident that there's a lot of
interesting cooperations synergisms and
antagonisms between microbes and how
they function
and this is really important when we're
looking at how we model biofilms so how
do we go about modeling biofilms
this is really well summarized in this
uh infographic here where we have what
is seen as essentially a Continuum of
high we model biofilms from the very
very lab-focus stage on the left hand
side which are normally seen as very
cost effective a high throughput quite
easy to perform yet they are very poor
mimics of the mvivo infection
and then this goes all the way through
to the more complex models such as the
inverter bit uh kind of in Vivo models
non-mammalian ones
human organized models which have had
very in success and a really interesting
area of current research and will be
have great application in the future
main going on to the mammalian models
which are expensive very low throughput
and also have ethical implications
so to delve into these a little bit more
just to give some examples of these
within vitro we can go from basic micro
plate assays through to the Calgary
biafun device which has been around for
about 20 odd years now and has really
helped in the research of pseudomon's
original genosa through to Colony
biofilm models which is what we
predominantly use and for our basic
research and investigation of whole
microbial interactions
and then what this then allows us to do
is build up basic research and science
understanding to then go on to more
complex models
and more complex models such as these
can look at the Lubbock wind bifur model
and the collagen model and this is
essentially designed to mimic a grade
one diabetic fruit ulcer and then into
other models such as the microfluidic
platforms which can then be used to look
at biophones microbiology under flow
conditions such as in a catheter for
example
and these then allow us to move into
other models and I would say that
there's a kind of bridging between the
in vitro and in Vivo and that's the X
Vivo biofin models and these generally
are performed on a porcine x-view
samples and such as the porcine skin
model which is um seeing great use in
the last few years
and also the porcine long model which is
used in some ways to look at pseudomonas
originosa biofinformation and treatments
in a cf-like condition
and then moving on we have the in Vivo
models with the invertebrates such as
melanoma Galleria or the greater wax
worm and these can be used to monitor
biofilms growth especially if you have
things like a lux reporter as can be
seen here and when you have biofoam in
formation inside the wax room you can
see it you can see it through the wax
worm and then also moving into things
like C elegans as well where you can use
things like gfp reporters as well to
visualize the microbes
and then moving into the murine area
we have the complex
um biofilm models such as this one here
which is a one that we use at the
University of Notting which is a
subcutaneously implanted uh infection
sites and there which is allowed to heal
and then the infection is monitored
longitudely using ivys and this work is
performed by Dr Jenny Luckett and this
allows us to do very high throughput and
longitudinal monitoring so with the same
mice which has
greatly reduce the use of mice in our
research and is also concurrent with the
views of the nc3rs in the UK
so it's quite evident there's a number
of biofilm models you need to better
translate these but we also need to do
the basic research to then get to that
stage
so what we've been looking at is first
obviously understanding how
polymicrobial biofilms can interact and
the best way to do that was to go back
to the start so what we've done
and spent quite a few years working on
standardization of a polymicrobial
colony biofilm model and making sure
that is reproducible in a number of labs
including collaborators in America
so this model is very simple but is
um quite complex to set up in the first
place as it requires making sure that
the microbial species here are at the
right point and in generally what we
found is on initially doing this work
that we would have complete overgrowth
of pseudomona Sera genosa therefore what
we've then designed to do is delay this
addition to then get a stable biofilm
which can then be used for example to
test uh novel compounds but then also
look at testing things like wind
dressings and this can have a number of
endpoints such as the standard Colony
forming unit analysis or looking at
things like viability Imaging through
live data and
kind of vocal Imaging and then looking
also at things like viability PCR to
um then establish live dead populations
through PCR
so what we've done with that is then
apply this to a number of models and
areas
such as the visualization of how these
biofilms form so what we found is
actually very there's actually a spatial
temporal
um formation to these and what we can
see here is the candidate objects which
is in the green in the center of this
image and then around it in magenta is
the staphylococcus and it clusters
around it and on the edge of the
colonies of Canada begins we can see
hyphenation
and then after the 20 after the addition
of pseudomonas regionosa at 24 hours we
can see the
integration of pseudomonas into that
biofilm structure we've seen maturation
of the candida albicans in green the
magenta which is the staphylococcus
clustered around that and also in and
around the high fit of the candida
albicans and the pseudomonas is starting
to make headways into those structures
as seen in that middle image with
pseudomonas represented in cyan
and then what we see at 72 hours is a
disruption of that initial
um
tertiary structure
and then what we see now is a
homogenization almost of the cinemas
throughout that biophone
a lot more hyphenation with the candida
and the staphylococcus distributed
throughout and this is a quite a stable
biofilm structure that we've managed to
grow for a number of days past this
point
but then when you also look at these
polymicrobial biofilms they look like a
biofoam but it's a colony of iPhone
model so we need to make sure that it is
definitely a biofilm and to do that
we've done carbohydrate staining and
also looking at extracellular DNA which
are both Hallmarks of a biofinformation
so 14 hours we see this kind of biofilm
structures and you can see in the top
left there's some evidence of what was
one of these uh candida albicans yeast
and hiful structures but then when we
moved to the 72 hours and then we see
these distributed change in the biofilm
architecture in green and then also with
the distribution of the extracellular
DNA seen in blue
so we know we now have a biofilm in this
polar microbial biophone
and then another thing to always
consider as well is the environmental
conditions under which the tests are
conducted and this is really exemplified
by a paper that was published earlier
this year which showed the impact of uh
the environmental oxygen conditions
where we have narmoxia which is classed
as 21 oxygen and the hypoxia one percent
oxygen and this is a really strong
driver for the filamentation of Canada
albions so moving away from that yeast
growth morphology towards the morphology
of forming hyphae and this is really
interesting work that allowed them to
then unlock the molecular mechanisms by
which this is regulated and as you can
see here there's quite a stark
difference between how the candidobiance
grows under normalox and hypoxic
conditions this is important to consider
when we look at translational research
so another thing that we're able to then
do is look at well what about
standardized testings for the
translation of research so standards
claims for antimicrobial activity and a
very easy one to focus on is that of
wound dressings so this is General
regards this is an antimicrobial fabric
so one of many tests that can be used to
claim antimicrobativity is the aatcc 100
and it can be used to test for this and
the standardized methodology that is
um available for people to conduct and
to provide a claim for antimicrobial
activity
yet when we look at this it tests versus
plantonic bacteria yet this is not the
preferred growth load of microbes which
is in the sessile biofilm state
yet there's there is no requirement for
testing versus biofilms in the standard
when we know that this is dominant and
we know that these biofarms are also not
just monor species but poor microbial in
nature so using the colony bifur model
that's polymicrobial
I was able to show that while you have
these monasteries biofilms treating them
with chlorohexidine which is used as a
topical
um
antimicrobial especially for
decolonization before surgery for
Staphylococcus aureus predominantly and
we see that on a one percent solution
which is below what's used surgically
that we have reductions from the control
uh to chlorhexidine one percent of about
two Logs with
pseudomonosaurugenosa a five to six log
function with a staphylococcus aureus
and a two log reduction mechanic
albigens yet when we shift into this
polymicrobial model with pseudomonas
staphylococcus aureus and candida all
begins in sc5314 we see that there is a
greater recalgrants to that
um treatment with one percent
chlorhexidine and this just exemplifies
why
um testing and a polymicrobial nature is
very important compared to just testing
versus
microbes on their own especially in
biofilm States
so then another study that we Then
followed on with this after validation
of that model and seeing this
interesting effect was to look at the
impact of currently available commercial
wound dressings represented by one two
three and four and on the impact of this
program model and it was really
interesting to see that when we
performed this buy from challenge with
the whole intact of iPhone we didn't see
any viability
impact with three addresses or one of
the dressings had an impact out of those
four and this was also seen to a lesser
extent when we also looked at disrupting
those biofilms and then challenging the
wound dressings where we still saw a
very high level of recovery of the
microbes
so what that's led us to is allowing to
look at this translational aspect to
look at why treatment May Fail why wound
dresses potentially may not translate
from the plantonic standard testing to
killing biofilms and then it's also
allowed us to look at
how we can harness new technologies to
look at investigating
how these microbes talk to each other in
these polymicrobial biofilms
so looking at pseudomonas originosa as
our organism of choice at Nottingham
Cinemas originosa is regulated by three
Quorum sensing systems so we have the
lassar and the rhlr which are NSO
homicide lactones so ehls and we also
have the pseudomonas quinolone signaling
pqs governed by p q s r
and these three systems work in tandem
to regulate the pseudomous originosa and
its virulence determinants
so one of the things that we've used
these models for is looking at how we
can modulate that interaction that
regulation and also what would make
effective targets to reduce virulence
and one of the ones that has been
actively looked at is antagonists of
peak USR so knocking out the pqs
signaling in pseudomon's Originals which
has a number of beneficial effects
being able to see is with the pqs
knocking out the pqs with this pqsr
antagonist in this paper that we
published last year
the part of this pathway is formation of
compounds such as hhq and pqs which are
involved in the biosynthesis pathway of
pseudomous and its regulation
and what we're able to see is that when
we add this antagonist we're able to
knock out the production of these
molecules in most cases but not all some
of them are resistant to this and these
are the essentially representative five
Clays of pseudomous reginosa but more
importantly what we can do with this is
looking at combination of the Quorum
sensing inhibitor so here we have what
we call 61 and in combination with uh
antimicrobial that is commonly used such
as ciprofloxacin we're able to at early
points in the biofilm
essentially sensitize it again to the
antibiotic this is quite important early
research and it also has Downstream
impact as well because when we knock out
these Quorum sensing systems we can
impact things such as Pi assignment
production which is seen as a variance
determinant in these infections
yet when we're doing this research we
don't exactly and have the capability to
see into these biofilms and also to map
the distribution of these chemicals
metabolites that are in conflict between
microbial species and also between
um the host as well so what we've been
doing is validating and standardizing on
a new bit of equipment at the University
of Nottingham it's also present in npl
down in London and that's called the 3D
Orbison so this is essentially uh a very
Advanced method of mass spectrometry it
has high spatial resolutions for biom
molecules and it can also be done in 3D
pinpoint where these are in complex
samples and there's a number of modes
that this can be run in of special
importance being profiling so we'll be
able to drill down through a biofilm and
see the structure inside it and then
also
to build up 3D imaging once the initial
um
experimental validation data has been
obtained
so what this looks like
is we have the biofilm and the top left
pre-measurement
and then we have post management where
we then expose it to essentially an ion
beam that will etch off the biofilm and
put it into the mass spectrometry for
analysis and from this we've been able
to detect a number of the key
biosynthetic compounds in the pqs since
it's a pathway such as the C7 pqs c9201
c9pqs
and from that you're also able to get a
distribution through the depth as well
and just for clarity the NDM is part of
the coating on the side the indium tin
oxides which helps with the signal to
noise ratio for the orbison's analysis
so we've been able to work through this
and then look at it in a dual species
nature at the moment where we've been
able to establish levels of compounds
that are in the biosynthesis pathway
such as HQ hqno which has interactions
with staphylococcus aureus nhq and pqs
and what's quite interesting is when we
then look at this in combination with
staphylococcus aureus we're able to
reduction in the levels of these
compounds and also the the impact that
it has on the staphylococcus through
other visualization methods such as kind
of focal microbiology
so hopefully
um we'll be able to use this further
Downstream to then look at producing 3D
imaging maps and then also working at
quantifiable concentrations from these
Imaging techniques such as the orbisons
but this is where it helps us to also
analyze other complex samples such as
patient samples where we'll then be able
to take that analyze it and tell what
microbial species are present through
Hallmark
um chemical species such as things like
hhq pqs pseudomonas produce or aips for
Staphylococcus aureus
so at the end it comes down to what we
need in the area of biofilm research is
the understanding that there is no
perfect biofilm model
what it requires is for people to use
the right biofilm model at the right
time
and also to make sure they can address
the question that has been asked of the
research what are you trying to mimic
and is what you're doing appropriate to
mimic that situation especially when you
want to do say a compound screen go for
an early in vitro model to compare
screen before moving on to further more
advanced models that are also more
costly and time consuming as well
and ultimately what we need to do is to
create an agree on standardized models
for testing biofilms for assessing
claims of anti-biofoam activity not just
antimicrobial antibioform activity and
what that is going to require is the
creation and maturation of global
biofilm networks and that's going to be
key to doing that and there are a number
of centers such as the national biofilm
Innovation Center in the UK
Montana State biofilm group skelsey in
Singapore as long as costine in Denmark
and a few others as well which are
international leaders in that area
and what's that ultimately will also
have to entail is the collaboration
between Academia and Industry to achieve
these goals to form standards groups to
make this a realization
and these will be the goals that need to
be done to change this translation of
research and making sure that what we're
doing successfully translates from the r
d and Academia industry through to an
actual efficacious product on the market
so with that I'd like to thank um the
members of my lab and Miguel Kamara
Manuel Romero farisukareth and my
collaborator Brianne Griffis for the
mass spectrometry work the facilities at
the University of Nottingham and also
our funders thank you very much for
listening